our ongoing series issue that issues
that matters explores the challenges and
possible solutions for our country's
greatest concerns this morning we're
looking at the opioid crisis
Pennsylvania Congressman Tom Marino
withdrew his name yesterday from
consideration as the next drug czar it
followed an investigation by 60 minutes
and the Washington Post into a law he
sponsored a Drug Enforcement
Administration whistleblower told 60
minutes the law made enforcement of
suspicious opioid distributions more
difficult
41 attorneys general around the country
have subpoena drug manufacturers and
distributors for information and
documents they want to know how opioid
medications are made marketed and
distributed Pennsylvania Attorney
General Josh Shapiro is one of the
attorneys general looking into this
crisis an average of 13 people die every
day in his state alone attorney general
Shapiro joins us now good to see you
good to be with you thank you for being
here what from what you've seen in the
past few days how has that changed your
approach to what's happening right now
it was important journalism it was
shocking journalism for a lot of people
it didn't surprise us a whole lot but it
really put an exclamation point on the
work we're doing I can tell you that our
investigators have new questions as a
result of the good work that 60 minutes
and CBS News did and we are continuing
that investigation both of the
distributor's the three that you
highlighted in your piece as well as the
manufacturers look this crisis is of
epic proportion we're losing we lost
6,000 Pennsylvanians last year tens of
thousands of more across this country
I've had moms and dads in my arms crying
over the loss of their loved ones we are
getting to the bottom of it and for a
lot of people they don't understand well
what's the connection between the opioid
industry and the heroin crisis look 80%
of heroin users start with a legal
prescription drug yeah so if you want to
get it the supply chain here you got to
go after the pharmaceutical industry and
we are undeterred unlike the folks in
Congress we are undeterred by these big
pharmaceutical lobbyists and all the
money they throw I think what disturbs
me most is just how reckless and callous
they've been it seems like they just
want to turn a profit and they're
willing to put these highly addictive
medications out there
seemingly turning a blind eye to the
fact that these pills are being dumped
in communities especially in rural
communities across this country it's
it's both upsetting but it's also you
know pushing us to move forward to deal
with this crisis I want to point out
that one of the distribution companies
that you're investigating and was named
in the 60 minutes report Cardinal Health
has released a statement saying this we
maintain a sophisticated
state-of-the-art program to identify
block and report to regulators those
orders of prescription controlled
medications that do not meet our strict
criteria but specifically what are you
investigating that the distributor's may
be doing how are they are they breaking
a law potentially potentially and that's
what our investigation is seeking to get
to the bottom of look nor let me put
this if the laws that are the problem
well certainly we need tougher laws I
mean certainly we need Washington to
actually do something to help us but
we're not waiting on Congress we're not
waiting on the president we're working
hard in this state's 41 state Attorneys
General coming together what have you
heard that before actually folks coming
together across state lines across part
that reminds me of Big Tobacco it
reminds me of what the Attorney
General's did on Baker who are the
targets then of these 41 Attorney
General's the three distributors that
you cited and the five manufacturers and
you asked a really important question
you what did these distributors
potentially do wrong let's just take a
simple example you have a pharmacy
somewhere in central Pennsylvania and
they're sending a thousand of these
highly addictive
you know oxycodones to that pharmacy
each month then all of a sudden it's ten
thousand and fifty thousand and a
hundred thousand pills you know there's
a responsibility on these distributors
to actually look into that to flag it
and to report it and we wonder whether
or not they did that that's not the
doctors prescribing these pills
absolutely look we've doubled the number
of arrests of doctors in my office in
Pennsylvania who were diverting or
taking these legal pills and using them
for unlawful uses so we are going after
the doctors but you have to hold the
pharmaceutical companies accountable and
that's what we're doing in this
investigation we should mention we did
reach out to the manufacturers it named
in your lawsuit allergen and TSA they're
cooperating Purdue and endo
international have not responded Janssen
pharmaceuticals told CBS News they quote
firmly believe the allegations in these
lawsuits are both legally and
actually unfounded your response first
off we haven't filed a lawsuit yet it's
an investigation and those are just a
lot of words look we deal with these
suits every day right these are powerful
people we sit across from them every day
we're not afraid of them and that's why
our investigation is full steam ahead
aided by the 60 minutes report and we're
gonna get to the bottom of it we're
gonna change corporate behavior and
we're gonna hold them accountable to
Nora's question how much how much legal
ground do you believe you have versus
how much moral force you think you can
bring to this I think we have both we
certainly have the moral force and we
have plenty of laws in our states that
are gonna enable us to hold these folks
accountable recover for our respective
states and to make sure most importantly
we change corporate behavior we cannot
continue to lose the lives we're losing
in the United States of America and the
pharmaceutical industry has an important
role in this process and we're gonna
hold them accountable it's been a smart
discussion we can hear your passion
thank Josh Shapiro thank you thank you
thank you